what is your strategy
my strategy going to big brother canada
is playing a social game i feel like
everybody says that but i definitely
want to be under the radar be everyone's
best friend their brother sister
wherever they need me to be i will be
that and then when needed i will cut
through what kind of personality will
you clash with
i think i'm gonna clash with like a
cocky stuck up rude personality i feel
like that doesn't really mesh well with
me um it just kind of grinds my ears i
don't know like i have different kind of
a reason or something like you know
they've had this i don't know there may
be a reason for something but i think
someone's super cocky super full of
themselves um
but then again i feel like everyone
always has good traits about them within
that bad so i don't figure it out there
we'll see maybe like someone's super
nice i can't stand them i don't know
i don't know
um showmance our nomads nomads
i'm taken and i just i just wouldn't
ever i just can't like act like you
don't like me i don't pda no thank you
canada is going to root for me because i
am representing surrey b.c
oh that was so lame oh goodness oh god
that's cringe
yeah and also i'm representing the
punjabi community being the first
punjabi girl i'm so honored i'm just a
regular girl second generation i feel
like there is a stereotypical punjabi
girl um image out there in the media so
if i saw myself on the show i feel like
it would make a massive impact so i'm so
honored to be able to you know represent
you